from fox news black you know what it's
funny okay
even fox news won't go as far as the
rest of the mainstream media when
they're talking about these stories they
say
black lives matter protesters storm
oklahoma capital over gop bills
protecting drivers fleeing riots
police from doxing more than two dozen
protesters filled
gallery while oklahoma house was in
session
that's the news fox news will not say
insurrectionists
storming you know insurrectionists they
won't say it
the mainstream press will say about
trump supporters all day and night all
day
there's no real meaningful opposition i
gotta be honest
you look at uh fox news right sean
hannity was like the derrick show of
inverted was the correct verdict
tucker carlson was like no it wasn't
even fox news can't agree
on whether or not they support the cop
or they support
the guilty verdict even when you look to
fox news and other conservative outlets
they're not going to say insurrectionist
storm the capital they won't do it
so that's that's a huge issue i suppose
these
these extremists are protected even by
conservative media
why i guess because conservative me
doesn't want to play that game for the
most part
yeah i think i'd probably be more in
line with
with hannity on the shove in question
but when it comes to the capital being
stormed
even though again this is not the
capital this is in oklahoma
nothing that happens in oklahoma matters
as they say
so it doesn't matter uh yeah it's crazy
to me i think
part of it might be that fox wants to
try to appear more neutral because they
have the
like the baggage being considered a
biased network and other networks just
don't people know cnn is biased but for
whatever reason they've
been able to play themselves off as
neutral for many years
i don't think fox has had that luxury i
really do think it's an overreaction to
the perception that they're biased
maybe yeah i don't know it's really
weird tucker carlson's opinions are very
very different from
the traditional opinions of the network
you know what i mean yeah no and that's
part of why i enjoy watching him so much
yeah no i think the issue is there's
the on the right and the disaffected
liberals anti-woke anti-establishment
there's the rules and the exceptions and
they differ from the rules and
exceptions and the democrats said
on the democrat side you have
establishment media the active
stenographers for the state
and they will say the most insane and
most extreme things like i don't know
maybe they'll say something like
tucker carlson had a psychotic break on
his show last night because he was
laughing like you know like a crazy
person
sure i guess tucker laughed you know
outrageously
it wouldn't call it a psychotic break
but you'll get that from you know
mainstream press you'll get that from
partisan left press
if that's a psychotic break what do you
call what kamal has been doing
she's like breaking down into psychotic
laughter constantly it's like her whole
thing
well most of what there's a difference
between
megalomania and psychosis okay that's a
really good point
it's a fine line but i suppose there is
a difference can we
you know you know is missing from kamala
though a mustache
that she can twirl squirrel oh my
goodness you gotta twirl the mustache
i i i would be more believing of it i'd
be like yeah i can see it
no i mean it's interesting so this was
what this was an anti-rioting bill
oh yeah oklahoma city's passed the
anti-writing bill they made it law
and this one's interesting i think this
this one's actually a bit better than
florida's because this one makes it a
misdemeanor to obstruct a roadway
instead of a felony
i don't think it should be a felony for
a bunch of protesters block a street it
should certainly be illegal
they make it a serious felony you get up
to a year in jail for blocking a street
i think that's appropriate i think
non-violence of disobedience should be
you know like respected to a certain
degree you do it you still get arrested
though you commit a crime blocking the
street you get arrested
i'm just thinking out loud here i don't
really have a strong opinion on whether
that should be a misdemeanor or felony
but if you block the street
you could prevent an ambulance from
getting through and people can die as a
result well that's a different charge
though isn't it that
okay so if there was a but then here's
the question if i'm blocking a roadway
and
there's some amount of traffic and many
cars back there's an ambulance which i
can't see and now somebody dies but i
was unaware
what kind of charge is that do i still
get hit yeah that's murder yeah okay so
we're fine with that the issue is
a felony charge for you know marching on
the street and saying dumb stuff i don't
think so man that means you can't vote
you can't get a gun you can't yeah
you know we had we had this debate
already other day i think with will
chamberlain he was very much in favor of
the of the felony
but in oklahoma city they passed this
anti-riot bill
and it specifically says that if you're
fleeing a riot
you're not civilly liable if you know
you hit somebody
and they're they're protesting the
storming the capital demanding the right
to like mercilessly beat drugs that's
insane that's insane right
and i think i think that's probably the
the happy middle ground if you could
call it that
to just say yeah no if you're behind the
wheel of a car and
people are riding and you feel
threatened it's fine to just drive
through them it's an ugly situation you
hope you're never in it but people have
to be able to protect themselves
i don't know it sounds like something
that should storm the capital yeah i
think they should storm the capital
here's the thing tim this is an
anti-rioting bill and you could say it's
ironic that they ride it over an
anti-writing bill but they really didn't
write they committed insurrection so
there was a couple moves ahead of us
i'm confused as what the rules are right
now like there are none
am i allowed to support black lives
matter insurrection or is that still
promoting insurrection you know what i
mean like of course not tim you of
course
there are no rules there are no
standards for them of course you can
support that kind of thing
it's a mostly peaceful insurrection yes
yes
so as long as you say peaceful protest
you can say whatever you want right
basically yeah you can do whatever you
want
the the the incoming peaceful protests
that we will see over the summer from
black lives matter
will leave a wake of destruction fire
and death
it's like well dude they said it was
peaceful all right it's right on the
flyer mostly so
is it obviously something today yes we
did do a cartoon it's called mostly
peaceful maxine waters if you guys want
to check that out that was
the third of a series of as i mentioned
three cartoons we did in one week
we're pretty proud of it check it out
wow
she's a hoot you know you know one of
the challenges with this because we were
talking about before
we went live i was like this is just so
redundant i know it's like this time
like oh look they did it again and the
media doesn't care i know well this is
hilarious because
every once there's a video i did a
couple years ago on gun violence
and this must have been 2015 2016 maybe
2017
i bet i still got it wrong even though i
threw three different years out but
in the video i say that one of the
reasons we need the second amendment one
reason people should be able to own
assault rifles is because inner city
shop owners and other people living in
these neighborhoods might need to be
able to protect themselves from multiple
people when there are riots because the
media irresponsibly riles up racial
tensions
and so people are commenting on this
over the past couple months
oh you're a prophet you saw this coming
it's like no it's just that the news
media is all reruns this stuff keeps
happening
over and over and over again i didn't
predict anything i just made a cartoon
about what was happening
and it's relevant again you know would
have been funny if bernie sanders won
and then they were like the bernie bros
they're staging an insurrection at the
capitol because they were doing that
like you you were mentioning that
earlier weren't you
somebody earlier was like bernie almost
got the same oh we were talking about
that
i wasn't the one who brought it up but
no it's true bernie almost got the exact
same treatment that
that trump got yes where they were
they're calling bernie bros they were
saying they were really violent they
were
or at least that their rhetoric was
violent they were being misogynistic and
harassing women on the other
it's almost like all this social justice
stuff is just an excuse to silent
dissent and they don't actually care
it's just about getting their political
goals across
that sounds about right man but i'm just
you know i kind of wish we were in that
timeline where it's like bernie sanders
he's like go home go be peaceful you're
my special voice
go home my special voice everything it's
true go home it's okay could you imagine
a special voice
i mean the funny thing is we are seeing
the bernie bros committing acts of
violence
burning things down they're
substantially more violent than trump
supporters
are yeah i guess we don't know exactly
how many of them are bernie bros but we
know they're so
come on dude yeah i know i know there's
very homeless a lot yeah yeah
and they're going around burning stuff
down and the media is just like let's
not
you know bernie you know he said vote
for hillary
now if he hadn't said vote for hillary
they would have been like this
this seditionist movement within the
democratic party well it's crazy though
because
i mean you look at this you look at
these riots that are occurring and it
just becomes obvious that this is like
the militant arm of the democratic party
i'm not the first to say this but
there's sort of a
like a wink and a nod you know yeah
they're cutting them loose they're
dropping the charges
yeah i would i would just you know i
don't want something like that to happen
i would just i have to admit i'd be
thoroughly entertained by bernie sanders
being like
the one percent need to face justice
take to the streets and then like auntie
was running around and they were like
waving bernie flags that have trump
flags and they're like
you know he's like here's how we're
going to destroy the one percent
find a small business and throw a brick
through the window
that will show them i don't know what
antifa is thinking but it seems to be
their strategy that's their plan it's a
brilliant strategy
it's really unfortunate we we live in a
it's
it's a like you said it's a rerun man
it's like 2021 it was going to say the
same thing over and over again
no because it's just going to get worse
and worse and worse till it collapses
right if if we don't change course this
can't just keep happening
it'd be cool if it was kind of like game
of thrones though where we have this
really intense
first few seasons and then the last
season is just like a crudely drawn
horse and we're all confused to what's
happening
no i think we're getting i gotta be
honest i do think it's like that right
so
2021 was like the first six seasons i
guess of game of thrones where
everyone's all like it's intense and
everyone's like
donald trump it's the most important
bang in the table and now we have this
year
where the democrats are like child knife
fights are normal and
yeah no that was horrible uh the two
girls no need to the democrats saying
arguing that no teenage knife fights are
normal in the police didn't you ever go
to boy scout camp you know you get your
whittling chip
and then all of a sudden people just
start like stabbing each other
dude when when i was a kid in in
southern chicago every child was running
around with some kind of knife exactly
every button no they wanted to make sure
everyone had a knife that's fair how how
insane is this that they they literally
were defending that
that's that's what i'm saying they
jumped the shark right fonzie was you
know you know jumped the shark john
fancy
yeah yeah jet ski right is that what it
was no i think
he jumped i think he jumped a shark on
water skis or something he was over a
ramp that was a motorcycle it could have
been
that's where we're at i was sitting
there and you know i was i was working
on my my show for 4 p.m
and i'm like i have this thing about you
know new new police training measures
and police accountability oh my god this
is gonna be this is crazy the police
department's responding
and then i see these these tweets where
it's like children have knife fights all
the time and i was like that's normal
bro
no didn't you tim didn't you have a
brother i mean come on this is normal
stuff
me and my sibling got into knife fights
i'm just like no i want to know how i
got these scars
[Laughter]
i'm just telling people like please if
there's any segment of mine you've ever
shared
share the one where i'm showing the
tweets from democratic personalities
saying that teenagers should be allowed
to have knife fights tim
normalized kids having no no no no no
they said that not me i know i'm saying
no i know i know i'm just i'm making fun
of them
you have to have the clap emojis in
there normalize kids
having a knife and then it was uh it was
bree newsome
who like locked her accounts because
everybody was like yo are you are you
serious with this but like also how do
we lose that valerie jarrett
yeah it's belly jerry she's like let the
children have their knife fights
how do we live in a world where using
the wrong pronouns is violent
but like it's normal for kids it's so
weird they're hypersensitive
about really weird things like if you
use the wrong pronouns or like if you
don't support the welfare state you want
everyone to die but then they're like
super in favor of abortion apparently
now child knife fights are like a normal
thing
it's weird how they just they shut their
empathy bro get out of cities
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you